okay so the implanted associations asks
is principle is this word association
game it's actually predicated I would
say on psychoanalytic ideas most
particularly on Union idea because young
developed the Association has many many
many years ago whether it purports to
investigate whether you are
unconsciously biased towards one group
or against another group could be gender
could be ethnicity could be raised it
could be attractiveness whatever but the
problem is is that when you give the
same person the damn ing twice they
don't get the same result so there's a
rule for diagnostic tests and the rule
is the reliability test retest
reliability has to exceed something like
point eight or point nine point eight at
least so the Big Five does that I
suggest do that but there's a damn
there's damn few tests that pass that
reliability criteria and the IAT is only
reliable you don't remember precisely
but I think it's about point five which
isn't even it's not even near close
enough to be used as a diagnostic test
plus it's not valid so what does that
mean let's say I assess your unconscious
bias and give you a diagnosis well
there's no evidence that it predicts
your behavior so so what is what good is
it what good is it
well it's good if you want people to
send you to retraining exercises so that
you can have two perceptions adjusted in
the direction that's in your
organization in this based basis process
and that's happening everywhere I got
letters this week already for people at
CDC it's becoming mandatory their state
might cost little same thing and they've
decided that all of their micro
institutions within the hospital will be
equitable to be fifty percent women and
fifty percent men at every single level
of the organization or the organization
is corrupted and present it's like it's
enough it's spreading so fast you can't
believe I wrote Mouser tadashi and
Anthony Greenwald yesterday I've set it
off to some of my colleagues say are you
going to come out and make a public
statement about the fact that your damn
test is being used by pathological
people for nefarious purposes it's like
well we'll see what they have to say
about that is a bit more
my letters now but there's no excuse for
absolutely no excuse for and as far as
I'm concerned and part of the broader
corruption of social psychology you guys
may know or may not that social
psychology has been right with with
controversy and scandal over the last
three or four years and a big part of
reason for them to have corrupt
discipline and now use of the IAD for
political reasons is a perfect example
of them there's no excuse for it and the
people at st. Mike's you know they say
well this is scientifically validated
like no it's not and worse let's say you
do have unconscious bias just for the
sake of argument and you can measure it
reliably which you can omit it would
balance which it is let's say all those
things rinsing there's no evidence
whatsoever that those damn unconscious
bias training programs retraining
program has the effect that they're
supposed back house and there's some
evidence that they actually have the
reverse effect and maybe that's because
people don't realize being marched off
to re-education by the Reploids
after they seem diagnosed as racist even
if there's no evidence that they in fact
are so it's an absolute misuse of
psychology and in sentences politically
motivated it's politically motivated
it's an assault on freedom
anyways I made those two videos and I
tried to take the internet with these
people at UT to test if they made that
training mandatory for their HR people I
thought you don't have some right as an
employer to invade the unconscious
structures of your employees minds and
alter their political perspectives even
though you can't do it you don't have
the right to do that and to think about
it that's something you should do as a
matter of course as part of your ethical
duty is you really what that really was
that that's what you want to report it
to be able to do mmm
Figaro independently of your behavior
whether or not you're like you're a
racist or a classic sort or a misogynist
or whatever that happens to be and you
really think that the bureaucrats at the
University
example or bureaucrats anywhere for that
matter are actually capable and
qualified of doing such a thing properly
if I was doing far more damage than any
possible good